sur les quais de saône à tournus le
dispositif de secours est impressionnant
car aux alentours de 17h à l'occasion
d'un match de rugby
un drame s'est déroulé à la fin de cette
rencontre donc apparemment en sortant du
parking il ya eu à mon avis face et ce
qui se dit une erreur au niveau de
manipulation de pilotage
il ya une perte de contrôle du véhicule
le véhicule se serait engagé sur la
berge et aurait glissé la voiture une
petite citadine a donc fini sa course
dans l'eau sous le regard de nombreux
témoins
quand je suis arrivé j'ai vu la voiture
dérivés 45 degrés comme ça à poser dans
l'eau et un monsieur qui qui parlait à
la fenêtre et qui me disait fait quelque
chose on sait pas nager et on était de
trois personnes a commencé à se
déshabiller et nains kills même jeté à
l'eau et la voiture a coulé à ce moment
là très vite les secours sont prévenus
et s'organise mais la sonnette en crue
les courants sont forts et les remous
importants les moyens pompiers ont été
engagés au départ avec des plongeurs
donc sept plongeurs et deux embarcations
ce qui permet déjà d'assurer des
recherches de manière tout à fait
satisfaisante et nous avons eu à témoin
qui a proposé de mettre à disposition
son bateau et son sonar en plus pour
optimiser les chances de recherche
autre paramètre qui complique les
opérations de secours c'est la nuit la
visibilité très réduite et sous l'eau
c'est encore pire
il faudra ainsi trois heures de
recherches intensives et éprouvantes aux
plongeurs pour localiser la voiture et
ses deux occupants
sans surprise les deux victimes sont
décédées ce sont deux hommes originaires
de saône et loire âgé d'une soixantaine
d'années vers 21h15 leurs corps sont
extraits de la saône dès lors une
enquête de gendarmerie commence afin de
déterminer les circonstances exactes de
ce tragique accident